what's happening you bad [ __ ]
it's your uncle joey
wednesday april 7th let me tell you
something from the [ __ ] heart of new
jersey
uncle joey's joint is brought to you by
[ __ ] draftkings
why am i here because it begins tomorrow
the biggest
golf tournament of the year the masters
the boys are getting ready to hit the
links and you got to get ready for this
action
draftkings america's top rated sports
book app
is giving you a shot to land in the
green you get 100
to one odds that the golfer you're
choosing finishes in the top ten i told
you about this on monday
shake off the [ __ ] yips if you
haven't tried [ __ ] draftkings yet
it's time you got baseball going on you
got nba basketball going on
you already missed the tournament and
you're still sitting there like a
[ __ ]
bumpy you could turn one dollar into a
hundred dollars is simple pick any
golfer from this weekend's tournament
if they finish in the top ten you get a
hundred dollars i know you got a [ __ ]
dollar
sign up for the sports book draftking
sports book app now
today choose the golfer before the
tournament tees off tomorrow morning
draftkings is safe and secure so you can
deposit and withdraw your funds at your
convenience
it's a hole in one not to mention you
got the nba
not to mention you got [ __ ] baseball
where the lines are fresh right now
nobody knows dick
and you could make a little killing you
know what i'm saying a 50 a game movie
they got the boost they got the best
online casino in the world
poker blackjack [ __ ] you know you
name it
draftkings has it so stop [ __ ] around
download the top rated draftking
sportsbook app today right now
use promo code joey when you sign up to
turn a dollar
into 100 if the golfer of your choice
finishes in the top 10. that's code joey
to turn
a dollar into 100 hours for a limited
time only
at draftkings sports book here's the
fine print you know it's coming
you must be 21 year old i'm sorry all
right what are you going to do what do
you want me to do
[ __ ] go listen to an album new jersey
indiana pa
only new customers only restrictions
apply
see draftkings.com sportsbook for
details now
i hate asking you this because we all
got our [ __ ] problems
but if you have a gambling problem this
might not be for you okay
call 1-800 gambler in indiana call 1-809
with it but
if you're ready to make a little [ __ ]
baccala this is the [ __ ] place to be
draftking sportsbook app download it
right now
use promo code joey and turn a dollar
into a yardstick all right
right now download it cut this [ __ ]
i'm sorry about that the pubic head
disappeared now i got to throw a polyp
anyway
the joint is also brought to you by c
b d lion tremendous the best
how do i know i was on it before my
surgery
and they guided me through my surgery
like the [ __ ] kings that they are
whether it's the milk chocolate the
kinesiology tape
the bath balls the tincture the lotion
the [ __ ] the gummies listen
cbd line is in the top of that game what
i want you to do is just this start like
this
just go to cbdlion.com read
read read of what's available to you how
we can help you
let's find out what's what's bothering
you let's find out
what cbd can help you and is more
beneficial for you
that's how good cbd lion is they're not
telling you
they have a magic [ __ ] whatever
they're telling you that if you have a
problem
they could mix it with something that'll
help them maybe it's a bite of a
chocolate bar
maybe it's the chocolate bar and the cbd
cream you don't know
until you go to cbdlion.com and read the
third-party lab results
so do yourself a favor go to cbdline.com
right now
look at that cbd but most importantly
read and then you order something and
guarantee you
you'll tweet me in a month ago joey i
feel 100
better my elbow was [ __ ] up now i'm
jerking off cappuccino style you
understand me
that's what cbd lion does for you so go
to cbdline.com right
now preston joey or church and get 20
off your order delivered to the house i
take care of people
like i said go to cbd lion
and get the [ __ ] party started now
let's get
the podcast started that's what we need
to do here candles are lit
hey how you doing come on
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
greetings from podcastville what's
happening you bad [ __ ] uncle
joey
on a wednesday feeling good looking good
got my covert shot i'm not even gonna
tell you what happened until next week
cause
[ __ ] it that needs a whole different
[ __ ] podcast i'll tell you the story
but i did it and i got it over with i'm
[ __ ] happy it's wednesday it's a
beautiful day to be alive and
uh i hope you enjoyed the podcast monday
with eddie trunk
good dude you know what i'm saying good
[ __ ] so now i'm part of the
[ __ ] heavy metal family down here
in jersey with him jameson and my man
jimmy florentine
but this last week i uh
listen man if i'd miss
i miss things about california
and uh but i'm pretty much settled here
as you guys could see
by the smile on my face and my
comfortability and my
you know but i do miss what it was i do
miss what it was
what i was um i don't miss the condition
i was in
last year with you know the last eight
years with the edibles and all that [ __ ]
but i do miss pieces of that life if i
didn't tell you i didn't miss pieces of
that life
i'd be a [ __ ] liar uh i miss a lot of
the guys a little i miss a lot of the
camaraderie
you know one of the reasons i left l.a
one of the reasons i came back to jersey
let's get this out of the way was i
wanted to be closer to my family
in reality i have no blood family i was
talking about
the guys that i grew up with and uh
you know how they treated me when i was
growing up and i just wanted to be
closer to them
just in case we this country did go into
a hard time something happened
i wanted to be people around people that
i could trust and
uh not that i didn't trust people in l.a
but
in la you're out there by yourself i
wanted you guys to understand what
and i'm not complaining it was me my
wife and and
mercy and yes we had lee and we had our
own little clique steve simone and all
those guys
but as far as comedians like big timers
but they were always on the move so our
only time to see each other
was at the comedy store or any comedy
function or nothing
it was very rarely that we did anything
out of line
once i moved out of hollywood
in 2010 i think we moved into
uh north hollywood first in studio city
up there a lot of a lot of comics lived
up there in that area
it was more you know i would bump into
comics in hollywood at coffee shops or
if i went on hollywood boulevard to get
something or some a weed store or
something but
when i went to the valley the comics
that were up in the valley
were more family-oriented comics you
know i would bump into different
guys to 7-eleven and whatnot the one i
was in shock that i lived three blocks
away from
was burke christian i did not know this
when i moved into that area
i lived basically close to burke ricer
and then in time
i even moved closer to burke crystal
because i wanted
my daughter to go to that school bert
was the one that
told me to get into that area that the
school was a better area for my daughter
so in in in a sense it was you know i i
went
moved to where i lived because of bert
and i was close to the bird
and at first you know when i first moved
into that area i think it was 2016
i did that tour for uh live nation
i was really closer with bert you know
we were doing the birth cast
every day we were over there more you
know the legendary ralphie story
happened then it was a lot more fun then
our schedules got busier
and that's what made me sad about la
that
i really wasn't seeing joe i really
wasn't seeing eddie
i really wasn't seeing bird or tom or
any of my other
friends unless it was at the store you
know for the holidays we're all over the
place
for different you know events we're all
over the place
but there was one holiday that i saw
somebody
for like the four last four years i was
up in l.a
and that was burke christian we go to
his house and my [ __ ]
he had these chinese friends i love him
we would just talk about chinese food
being her
and you know bert's wife is great and
the girls and
i remember our last christmas there it
was kind of cool out and bert had just
put the pool in
and uh he was daring people to jump in
the [ __ ] pool and whatnot
and my daughter's like i'll jump in the
pool and people are like what and she's
like i'll jump in the pool and they're
like mercy
mercy mercy and mercy's looking i'm like
she's like okay i'll jump in the pool
and she had all her clothes on
and she started running towards the pool
right before she went she go stop
she goes mommy hold my ring and she
gives her mama ring out
all the [ __ ] things you could hold my
sneakers my socks
no take my ring i don't want it to get
wet
we [ __ ] died bert jumped in my
daughter jumped in
and that was the highlight of the night
daddy mommy hold my ring and we [ __ ]
until this day
whenever bert saw mercy go mercy all my
ring and mercy would just
shake ahead so bert was
kind of family you know mercy called him
uncle bert and uh
when i found out he was leaving for
three months i kind of got sad and i
heard he's coming back and he's
leaving for two more months so what i
did this week
was i did a little conversation with a
little chat
and uh it was great it was great seeing
him and he looks great
and uh you see it for yourself enjoy
meeting burke [ __ ]
god damn what's up kid
it's a great looking studio joey this is
the [ __ ] bar
this is the uh the zoom
uh room as we [ __ ] call it because
this is the bar
you know it's just you should have moved
in here this is a great [ __ ] ball
that's why i called the podcast
uncle joey's joined at first because we
were gonna do it from the bar but then
we couldn't get cameras and [ __ ] like
that you look good
so wait is that that's not the bar your
mom your mom owned is it
no no no this is the bottom of my
basement that's in your basement
yes [ __ ] we're gonna yank this out
though soon
oh i love it you know we we had a bar we
uh we bought a new house and we had an
old bar in it i wanted to keep the old
bar and
it just it was too much of a pain in the
ass to keep the old bar like
the [ __ ]
the to get back you had to lift up part
of the bar to get under it
and i guess it lost the spring so the
first time isla did it you know she
lifts it like this
and it [ __ ] drops and she looks holds
up her fingers and she goes
that was a close call and so leanne's
like we're getting rid of the [ __ ]
bar
that broke your [ __ ] heart how's the
little house
we haven't moved in yet we're still
building uh the podcast studio is done
the gym is done leanne's podcast studio
is done
but we're still we're going to be
building that thing forever i feel like
how you feeling you look great i feel
great joey i gotta be honest with you i
feel better than i've ever felt i'm
working out twice a day
um and i'm not drinking a ton
i'm you know having a couple glasses of
wine at night but i try to keep it i
keep it under a bottle
and i'm fine you know i can get up or
early and work out
i feel great um i'm probably the
happiest i've ever been
i just i'm bummed that like i can't get
on stage that none of you guys are
around
like getting podcast guests is hard as
[ __ ] [ __ ] now like to
find people that'll do it in studio and
you gotta like hope people come out to
la and no one has a reason to come out
to l
a l.a anymore no it's a nightmare i had
this
listen when we started this i said [ __ ]
i'll do it a la bill burr yeah you know
do
bill burr once a week and try to get a
guest and
getting a live guest is too rough even
for me
listen stand up is rough for me because
i'm putting 200 people in a room
even 41 people in a room i don't want
nobody to get this
whether it's light whether it's just a
mild cough
i don't want this associated with me at
any [ __ ]
point so we had to resume to zoom
and i think that people like you and i
could zoom because we have a prior
relationship
it's interviewing people that you really
don't know
on zoom that doesn't work well for me
like i said on the
and it's because there's nothing there
we have a culture you know
we know each other 10 15 years it makes
a big difference on a zoom
and i think that still comes through at
first i was a little hesitant about the
zoom
i didn't like it but mike got it to work
[ __ ] perfect
it looks great it sounds great so it's
about a good setup too you got a good
setup like
like some people do it i did one i'm not
going to call out names but i've done a
couple where they do it on their phone
and you're like hey man step up your
game a little bit like
but you can't you you can't say anything
to them because you're not sending them
over their equipment
and they don't get it like i had one
person do one from his car
like did it from his car on his phone
and i was like i just didn't use it i
was like i cut it short at 30 minutes
and i was like i appreciate your time
i was like i [ __ ] it was very tough
and i hope that people at home
understand the effort that we're putting
in like it's tough
you know what happens if you get a call
from tom that which you did
and he had covered you couldn't do the
podcast oh joey i did
so i did i mean i don't know how much of
this i've shared or not shared but
i get a call from tom and i go
now leanne and i both did uh christina's
your mom where's your mom's at
on like friday right we get a call we
both do it friday afternoon
leanne does it for an hour and a half i
do it for an hour and a half i talked to
tom on sunday
and i'm like uh what's up and he's like
i got kovid
i said shut up you got kovid he's like
yeah and i was like where did you get it
he was like in the
in the uh rehab facility we have and i
go
shut up i go to push get it he's like
yeah push got it too and i was like
when did she get it he was like well she
started showing symptoms like saturday
i'm like
i was with her [ __ ] friday liam was
with her friday now we're sitting with
my parents
in a big circle having wine and cigars
and i'm going mother
[ __ ] so he's like you know i think he
would have shown symptoms by now it's
been three days four days whatever
so then i gotta look at leanne and i go
wow that was a close call
the next week i'm with dr drew dr drew
for an hour and a half
he test positive and i'm like [ __ ]
and then i just i stopped man
i stopped and i'll be honest with you
joey i'm not good with people right now
i'm not good being around people
like i'm very short i i want i like want
distance
we went to rite aid the other day and uh
and i
all of a sudden people start getting in
line like it's like it's 1987 they're
like up on your back and you
i just got out of line and walked
outside i'm like i can't have
[ __ ] near me
like i haven't gotten comfortable yet
i'm happy you're saying all this
but you're the [ __ ] guy that last
march
10th yeah when covert was on a spread
you were at the garden drinking beers
with 20 [ __ ]
and didn't get it that weekend i'm like
he's dead
he's dead i saw you all summer on a boat
doing theater tours listen the mickey
mantle gene
theory is [ __ ] alive and kicking in
my world
don't let them tell you anything else
you have the mickey mantle gene
and the godzilla gene the japanese gene
they didn't get like you didn't get it
like
how many how many covet tests did you
take i've taken probably 150 codes me
too
me too every time you know i bought i
bought
[ __ ] i bought a hundred coveted tests
for myself
i bought them i got them on right now
yeah the rapids yeah
it was just you know i got sick and
tired of
doing comedy and getting a call there
was 41 people in the [ __ ] room
and i got two calls two times and i'm
like you know what
i'm not doing [ __ ] but but to go back to
the original
i do not feel comfortable either
i feel comfortable with mike i feel
comfortable if i know
where you do at night yeah i feel
very comfortable people were going still
to bars and restaurants
i i just no not really you know
i'm doing a lot of kid stuff that you
already did your daughters are grown you
know i'm
i'm coaching i'm not coaching jesus
christ she's playing softball
uh so i go to softball she just had a
green belt you know you go in there with
mass
the softball is outside but i can't even
imagine
going on the road all right i mean like
it is the
farthest [ __ ] thing from my mind
going to an airport getting on a plane
going in a hotel having somebody ask me
if i want to take a picture now
just burns my insides it's [ __ ]
covered season guy
there ain't no pictures put that [ __ ]
camera away
put that [ __ ] camera away when i get
vaccinated
if i get vaccinated when the time comes
today i got on the phone with somebody
about a vaccination
because i'm trying to get the johnson
johnson it's one shot i'll faint one
time
i'll sweat my [ __ ] i [ __ ] my blood
yeah
it's just a nightmare for me to get a
needle let me get the johnson
but joey it only covers you 85 i don't
give a [ __ ]
i don't give a [ __ ] just for as long as
i can get that card because in a year
we're not going to be able to do
anything without that card no
they're going to communize us we're not
gonna [ __ ] be able to do dick without
the [ __ ] card
and if you just get one moderna it's not
gonna be
in charge of it the problem i got is
that we have to do this every year
if we gotta do this every year then i'm
not gonna [ __ ] do it
oh yeah i'm just gonna take my channel
that's when you're gonna see people
flood
if this is an every year thing people
will start leaving out late quickly [ __ ]
in new york
they'll just start flying out to the
suburbs
if i have to now do you take a flu shot
every year no i i refuse to get flu shot
i've never taken a flu shot in my
[ __ ] life because i listen i owe the
doctor
i'm happy i moved from l.a because i had
a chinese doctor and they're [ __ ]
serious with their [ __ ] dr wu
i had an original guy but he retired
before the pandemic and he didn't give a
[ __ ] about
whether i took the shingle shot or the
tetanus shot this jimmy wu guy was
torturing me he was calling me at home
and [ __ ]
when are you coming down for your
shingles shot and i'm like
and also the pandemic hit they stopped
calling i'm like thank [ __ ] god
they stopped bothering with these
needles now you got to take another
[ __ ] covet test i just
uh a coveted needle i just don't even
know there's so much information that
floods you every day
that's what another reason why i put
stand up aside
yeah because i got so much on my plate
to make [ __ ] decisions
now i got to worry about stand up when i
wake up in the mornings i have to go do
stand up as i'm pissing
i'm like [ __ ] i can't believe i got
involved in this and then there was two
weeks in a row where they closed the
place down like i said because
customers had it and i was like that's
it
i'm not i'm not going through this
anymore we didn't we did that first run
we did that first run and they were like
uh they're like yo
those the drive-ins don't pay really
great you know because you gotta have a
you gotta bring your own stage
you gotta bring a crew of 12 people uh
with you everywhere to set up the stage
set up the gear
you gotta have a tour bus for those 12
people like it's just it's very
it's not cost effective those driving
tours um it's fun you end up making a
little bit of money but they had to
in order to do that first run we had to
put um we had to do stand-up shows
in in clubs and our first one was stand
up live
and cal and his shop had just gotten
covered there
and i was like i was like listen we're
gonna be really safe we enter through
the back
going to the green room we don't leave
the green room we do our show
we go out no one goes in the green room
we get in the green room and there's
like nine people in the green room
everyone's [ __ ] green and we're like
[ __ ] what the [ __ ]
and then and and i don't know the
numbers i think the numbers they did
like half capacity it seemed a little
more but
it's a big [ __ ] club the next place
we go to
is [ __ ] jam-packed and it's like no
one's wearing masks everyone's just
partying
and you're on stage going like okay like
i i
i get it you know this is texas we go to
[ __ ] oklahoma city
and it is wall to wall and they've got
they've got
uh they've got fans on the stage blowing
air to me because it's hot
and i go turn those [ __ ] fans around
blow the disease that way
i don't want to blow it to me you're out
of your [ __ ] mind and then i was like
i called off and
the last one i did was salt lake city
that was perfect he was he ran it he ran
it perfectly that was like
perfect and and i just was like no more
clubs i can't do any more clubs
like because look they were taking
temperatures they were being safe
but like my brain wasn't right like i
was
i'm up because you know what really
[ __ ] me up about this disease is that
it's
[ __ ] four or five days that you got
to wait till you showed symptoms
i'm like come on man like give it to me
that day i want it the next morning
[ __ ] wait there and wait till i die
it's like
oh i feel like you're in the zombie
apocalypse and you're the last
[ __ ] in the barn
and they're all around the barn and
you're just like [ __ ] i'm just gonna
run into the goddamn storm
you wake up in the morning you drink
coffee like oh i got a sore throat
i got i got high with rogan so so uh
january like my special comes out
january 17th [ __ ] gets crazy joe's like
yo can we do the podcast like
24th right now the the pandemic is in
it is kicked in no one's leaving their
house no one's on the 405. no one's on
the 101.
i make it to joe's podcast studio in
like seven minutes
right i'm there early joe's there early
you know what's crazy is he doesn't give
me a hug you know whenever you see joe
he gives you that wraps you up in that
big hug yeah doesn't give me a hug
just stands off like he's mad at you
right and you're like oh [ __ ]
and then he goes he's like you know how
you feeling how you doing
i said good i haven't left the house
like cool we go in he's like you wanna i
can use a cocktail and i was like me too
and then he gives me my own joint right
so i get my own joint he's got his own
joint
start smoking and then all of a sudden i
start getting paranoid i'm like i'm like
get a little shortness of breath you're
like oh [ __ ] i got the coven my throats
i can feel my throat really intensely
and i'm like i gotta get this i gotta
[ __ ] i just ended up murdering
alcohol
to get rid of the coven i am not
since i've got here when i first got
here the first month of august i smoked
with three hands
i kept i continued living like i was
living in l.a
and i moved into the house september 1st
we had an earthquake here what like
five nights after i move into this house
i am
[ __ ] hammered i am in my kitchen
stuffing my face with chicken cutlets
and [ __ ] popcorn and apples and
there's an earthquake and i'm so [ __ ]
high
that i go you know what i'll deal with
this tomorrow
and i just went to bed and i got up and
the next day people like [ __ ] you joey
you brought earthquakes to jersey with
you
he was right in the freehold like 15
minutes from where i'm living now
and i was like you know what i i gotta
stop
i was up at two three in the morning you
know my time zone had shifted
so what i did bert was i said [ __ ] it
no more edibles i stopped doing edibles
for a month
yeah and then i started taking edibles
to fall asleep
so at a quarter to 11 i drink my tea and
i put two edibles in the tea
capsules abx yeah the [ __ ] syringes
whatever i have
and i watch miami vice and by [ __ ] 10
to 12
papa's done really done i walk upstairs
i barely make it upstairs
i [ __ ] stumble into bed and i get my
[ __ ] eight hours but i swear to god
like today i have not smoked yet
really and you could hear it in my voice
there's no whistle
there's no whistle that's it that's done
that's done
if i smoke three times a day now it's a
lot
wow you know when i spoke to you and you
told me you were going away for three
months and then two months and that you
were gonna spend time with the girls
i asked myself what happened to [ __ ]
bert this was a guy that
could not function unless he was out
this was part of who he was and all of a
sudden he's telling me
i'm gone for five months i'm gonna stay
with the girls for seven months i'm like
what the [ __ ]
i knew there was more to the [ __ ]
story you're like i'm done
and the la and what people don't
understand is like the last 10 years
we've been busting our [ __ ] humps and
then there was 10 years before that that
we were bumped busting our humps in a
different way
so it's like for me i remember when they
first closed everything i'm like okay
i could breathe march and april yeah and
i'm like i hope i cancel may and i hope
they can't till [ __ ] june 2.
you know i did not want to go to a
casino in cleveland i wanted to stay at
knicks
you know in hilarities i was like i
don't want to [ __ ] play a deed i just
want to do next
next is such a great club it's easy the
hotel you got the chocolate shake
downstairs and the [ __ ]
great food over there in her lotteries
you know people don't understand
that yes i missed that you know i missed
the guy from
he's a great guy from [ __ ] salt lake
city
oh keith he really [ __ ] tried
i had to leave i got to cancel his room
because i was leaving august 19th
and i was supposed to be in this room
like september 4th it broke my heart
that i had a cancer but i wasn't ready
to do a weekend
i hadn't been on stage in seven [ __ ]
months i don't want people to see me in
that condition
i don't want people to see me rusty i
hate that [ __ ]
yeah yeah i i uh
i pulled out everything and then and and
uh you know look i'm
i'm i was when we first started it and
it was it was like i got to be really
honest i was driving
i was in the bus we were driving from dc
to new york and we were going to spend
that week in new york and everyone was
talking about kovid but no one knew
about it
but i was partying hard as [ __ ] partying
hard as [ __ ] and we stayed a week in new
york just to party
like just a party we parked the bus
outside in jersey all got hotels in soho
and just partied every [ __ ] night
when the pandemic is raging right raging
i saw you the one night at the garden
then the next night i saw a clip of you
with 200
people around you at [ __ ] uh you know
j
big j show big j and lewis gomez oh yes
and i'm like if this [ __ ] don't
have covert now he's never gonna [ __ ]
get it
dude when we were when we were at the
garden we i did this
twice right so we're at the garden twice
once is for a basketball game and once
once for a hockey game and so when we go
to we're at the basketball game
they go they come up and they're like
hey burt we're gonna put you on the big
screen i was like [ __ ] yeah and they're
like
hey is it cool if you kill a beer would
you have a beer to kill
and i go [ __ ] i don't i don't have one
let me go get one they go they went on
time
everyone started pouring their beers in
my beer i'm like [ __ ]
this is exactly how you this
[ __ ] and meanwhile on the other
side of town
michael yo is getting covered at the
gotham yeah
so it was so weird that you're on you're
at the garden at 48th street michael
yo's on 20th street with big ball
frankie and jeffy gurion
and three out of four of them get
[ __ ] covered in the room they're in
the green room
uh the owner didn't get it chris masili
didn't get it chris didn't get it so
there was four of them in the room in
the green room talking
three out of four of them went down with
michael yolk going down the hardest
uh lisa lampanelli's ex had his [ __ ]
heart he called his family and told him
goodbye
really on the phone yeah so think about
how [ __ ] lucky you are that while you
were at the garden jumping up and down
drinking covered beer
[ __ ] michael yo is over there at
gotham getting poor covert and a [ __ ]
pneumonia
to the point where he made a tape he
lost weight so you're a lucky [ __ ]
dude so
i was and then we did the exact same
thing the next night at the [ __ ]
garden again
and then partied all the way up through
wilkes-barre
all the way back down schenectady and
then hit up
uh hit up did the beacon did two shoes
hung out with james dolan who had covet
james dolan test cove
test positive for kobe the next week we
i'm doing shirtless pictures with him
and his family
backstage at the beacon go to dc
and now now the kovid's like everyone's
talking about it and i remember joey i
remember
i remember in that we're in the
constitution hall right
and i hear someone
cough and everyone turned and looked and
i went
oh this i went i got backstage i go guys
this is gonna get real serious
real quickly like if if if someone shows
up into one of these theaters with kovid
they're giving it to everyone like it's
gonna spread like this
and then next week we're indeed we're in
new orleans once again flying
on the red eye we party all night we're
walking through bourbon street we're
stopping in bars we're having drinks we
take a general meeting
i mean joey i'm everywhere i'm
everywhere we're getting
getting cube uh uh uh thai uh vietnamese
sandwiches
like just [ __ ] driving we're driving
around no one's got a mask on
and i remember seeing people with gloves
on and going like what [ __ ] lunatics
and and then they come into the bus and
they're like
hey uh i think they're gonna cancel the
show tonight and i was like
no and they're like yeah walk inside and
i look and all
the and this is when they start telling
us you know people that are really
affected are people over like 70
and all of the ushers all of them are
over 70 years old every single one and i
was like
all right yeah i go cancel the show and
then they're like hey i think they're
going to cancel
atlanta and alabama they're going to
cancel texas they're going to cancel
this
i think they cancel the two next weeks i
think you need to go home and i was just
like and that's when i got scared i was
like all right
we stay in the bus we take the bus home
we no one leaves a bus
we drink all the booze that we have in
the bus until we get home and by the
time we got home
we're stopping in new mexico at the
walmart
getting supplies because everything's
empty in l.a we're getting like
because no one in new mexico believed it
i got invited to a house party
they're like they're like it's not this
virus isn't real
it's not going to hit new mexico but
yeah we loaded up
and i was like god and i remember saying
joey i remember saying
to god in the back of the tour bus
leaving from dc
to new york to party for a week i was
like all right god
like i need a break i need like i need
something i can't because this tour
was at that point it was going every
week
until like june and i was like i just
need i think i'm gonna end up dying if i
don't get like a little break
like just something to some breathing
room like give me a tv show or like
something where i can work and i'm not
partying like this because i go i can't
do this
i'm like because you you know when you
you know when you get it
you know when you're you're partying and
you're you're taking it so far
that there's no bringing it back there's
no like you're only going to that level
every night
and then you need that night that week
home where you go all right i'm not
drinking tonight
and then you stop and then you can reset
things and then you go okay now we're
back to normal
i was at that like pushing it where you
know two shows
i have a drink on the second show all of
a sudden you're driving
to through the night you're partying
there you're partying through the night
you wake up
everyone has cocktails you pass out you
work out like and i was like i just need
[ __ ] i need i need like one week just
to reset things
and then be careful what you wish for
next thing you know i'm not drinking for
60 days i'm sitting in the house with
leanne and georgia
every night going what do you guys want
to watch on tv tonight huh
how are you adjusting now i'm great
there i'm really good now right now i'm
in
the sweet spot the girls just went back
to school so
they're like all of a sudden all the
anxiety that they've had
all the depression they've had because
it's been [ __ ] really hard on them
it was very hard on the kids it was hard
on my daughter last june
she was a different [ __ ] kid yeah and
it ate me alive because i couldn't help
her
nothing bothers you more than when you
see your kids
are having a hard time and you can't
help them there was no play dates
no no no there was a homeless was
starting to go to that park that we used
you know the parade we used to do and
end up at the park there
there's homeless now over there like
there's little gaps over there and uh
you know parents wouldn't so we were
with mercy
from nine in the morning we would go to
that church
on co on kofax and uh
whatever the [ __ ] there's like a church
with the parking lot we would go there
play basketball
we were just looking for in search of
parking yeah it was it was just
[ __ ] in search of parking lots every
day yeah riding your bike then we
started having play dates towards the
end but the damage had been done
when we got to jersey the first couple
weeks
we were staying in corporate housing and
we had a pool and she was great
and then we started we moved in and she
started
uh meeting the kids from the neighbor
and then my brother's wife died
and they had like a little celebration
from right when i got here
it was horrible and we all had to go
there and there was like 30 [ __ ] kids
and
we're all outside it was cool we were
outside
we all had masks on and i gave half my
family those edibles those capsules
and they were [ __ ] up two of my
brothers had to disappear and go sleep
in the car
but she had like a little anxiety attack
because she hadn't been around so many
people
yeah like she had she was playing with
nine or ten kids that had been the first
time
in seven months that she had played with
nine or ten kids
we were like where's mercy and we went
looking for she was two houses down in
the backyard just with a head in the
hand crying
because she's like i can't take the kids
that they're moving too quick i'm not
used to this and that's when i was like
thank god we got out of l.a because she
was just she was falling apart to be
honest with you
isla had a rough run of it at the
beginning because she just
she was like yo this is what i like i'm
not leaving my room and then she got
she started saying to me i'm really
covered conscious so i don't like i
don't want to
be around anyone like i don't i'm good
and we were like yo you gotta get
outside she was like no
i don't because georgia was riding bikes
with friends and going like going
socially distant like hanging out at the
park she going bike rides and isla
didn't do
[ __ ] and last yesterday they went back
to school for
i mean even taking i took eyelid at
school
for the first time she had like an
orientation like two weeks ago and she
was a mess joey like just a mess like
like she hadn't been around people
before and then yesterday they went
and she came home she's like i made six
friends today
and we were like really she's like yeah
she's like dad that was awesome and i
was like really and then georgia comes
in and she goes
i forgot i was kind of popular and i was
like i was like really and she's like i
have like a lot of friends i haven't
talked to anybody
and i'm just like they're there today
and then they start spring break
tomorrow so um what the [ __ ] is that two
days and then spring break
we've just been on a [ __ ] year break
what [ __ ] spring
[ __ ] break what they did the same
thing here they took off [ __ ] chinese
holidays and
jewish holidays forget the [ __ ]
holidays no holidays
yeah not now we've been out of school
for a [ __ ] year and you want to
celebrate the year of the tiger i'm not
not not this [ __ ] year
forget about this everybody gets a pass
this year martin luther king
what the [ __ ] we're on we're we're on
spring break this week
but they have been they've been back in
school
you know school started here four days a
week with no hitch
they were dying to close it yeah they
were dying
anything and they closed it two days
before thanksgiving
and let me tell you something these
[ __ ] parents
went [ __ ] ballistic do you understand
me if you think they were going to lay
down like those [ __ ] where we lived
in colfax
these parents attacked the
superintendent
they [ __ ] did a background check on
him they knew he was negotiating his
contract
they brought it up at the board of ed
meetings and guess what
my daughter's in [ __ ] school next
week five days a week it starts
well that's what's crazy is like it's
like la follows all these rules
and then you look at florida who's been
raw dogging it the entire time
and their code cases are the same as
ours
and we're the highest in the country
right now jersey jersey
is the number one for [ __ ] covert
right now and you know what they're
doing it's the restaurants
it's the [ __ ] restaurants that are
[ __ ]
putting in you know 90 000 people in
there
you go to a restaurant on friday and
saturday new jersey it's an hour [ __ ]
wait during the week there's nobody in
them
really so if i take my wife out it's
during the week if i go to dinner with
a friend it's during the week friday and
saturday [ __ ] you
they got you three feet next to the next
[ __ ] guy coughing and sneezing so no
for real yeah and they're not rolling
out the vaccines how they say they're
doing them i don't know what the
you know you don't know i'm one of my
fouchy all i know
is what you read i don't watch the news
i don't believe what [ __ ] they come
on the new you know
last time my wife turned on the news i
was at the computer
and the [ __ ] opening line was that
uh queens and
[ __ ] brooklyn had a transmission rate
of 4.5
something in queens was four point
something
and new york city's was 2.7 and then
they go
oh the next story is a good one new york
is opening 75
capacity so wait a second how the [ __ ]
are you opening you just told me right
now the
[ __ ] numbers are the worst so you
don't me and my wife looked at each
other like did you hear that one minute
they're telling you that the numbers are
the worst
and next minute they're telling you that
opening up the restaurants are 75
you know what i'm gonna mine my business
i didn't want to get the vaccine
i think i'm gonna have to get it like
justin johnson johnson
i'm in new jersey johnson johnson is
made in new jersey do you know nobody's
got it in new jersey
for real yeah i can't get a johnson
johnson in new jersey
johnson johnson's the one again huh it's
a one-shot deal
and you get 80 percent i think [ __ ]
you know from the whatever
but it's 99.95 percent that you're going
to live
so you know you just want to get it if
you have existing whatever
i i don't want to keep getting these
calls bert i don't want to do something
have a good time
and then two days later get a call that
the waitress had coveted and now i got
to go take a [ __ ] test
and now i already have plans with mike
to go to dinner and his family
and i got to [ __ ] sit there and tell
him mike i had covert so
sit on the other side of the table we
got to talk with a can and a string in
between because
i got [ __ ] covered you know i got to
get that's what you got to do that's the
only way you're not going to get cold is
if you get a can with a [ __ ] string
and talk to your guy 10 [ __ ] feet
away one day they tell you socially
distance is three feet
the next day they tell you it's six feet
you don't know who to [ __ ] believe
anymore
dude i'm just i'm you know i i not that
i'm not worried about me getting it
and me getting sick you know i'm
overweight if i don't i don't smoke i
run
i think my lungs are healthy and i don't
get super sick when i do get sick like
it
i've never got pneumonia i had i had
swine flu
once the h1n1 i had that that was the
worst i've ever been in my entire life
but i kind of was like it's not me that
i'm concerned about because i figure i
can get through it i've been sick before
i can do it
it's liam i'm worried about leans when
leanne gets sick
she gets [ __ ] sick like leanne
is like a bull if but if she gets sick
that woman shuts down and i was like and
that's who i was that's
like my big concern is you know you'd go
on the road
you'd be on the road doing it like a
two-week tour and i'd get a call going
mom's sick and you're like [ __ ]
that's when i was like charlie ann i was
like we gotta get you vaccinated [ __ ]
immediately
like you're just not did you get it
vaccinated
yeah leanne's got leon got her first
shot terry got a second shot
oh yeah yeah and she's feeling a little
shitty she's better today
she got it saturday i don't think i
don't know when leanne gets her she just
got her first shot i don't know when she
gets her second shot
she did the she's she's she's a savage
like
she i i i got anxiety about it joey i
get anxiety about like
getting in line and trying to get the
extra shot and all this [ __ ] i just kind
of like
i don't know i don't know are you gonna
get the shot i'm just gonna register a
republican
[Laughter]
i register felon so i'm even worse
but are you gonna get the shot i gotta i
gotta i got an appointment with my
doctor
uh in like a week i'm gonna see what i
can do
i mean you're going away right you're
going away for three months overseas
they're gonna probably make you get one
anyway i think so
for the crew it's a lot easier if you
get it so they don't shut down your
production
you know are you excited about shooting
this movie is it
something i haven't talked to i haven't
talked about it no one knows what it is
so don't tell anyone what it is i don't
know what it is
i don't know i'm really excited it's
going to be a [ __ ] blast everyone
thinks i'm going to rehab
really is that what you're telling
people
i'm telling everyone i'm going to rehab
have you but you've toned down your
drinking a little you look great bird
i feel great joey you know i like to
have i love to have a glass of wine with
liam when we start making dinner
i love to have like we're doing a
podcast in the new studio i love to have
a glass of bottled wine share a bottle
of wine with someone
it makes conversational flow a little
better what i'm not doing
is which which i was a big i was very
guilty of is
you know have that bottle of wine and
then open a second bottle of wine or
have a cocktail or have a beer
or or have three beers and watch tv i
just don't do that so like what i do is
last night's perfect example i did a
podcast with chris distefano
we opened a bottle of rose had a bottle
of rose uh
head home i had got a ride home and then
leanne and i opened a bottle so i had
like me and chris and and uh
don john um what's his name
christopher's son
don de peda jesus christ donna peta [ __ ]
i'm an idiot
uh we split a bottle of rose and then i
had a bottle of wine with leanne
and we split that and so i had like
probably around a bottle of wine and
then i just go to the
i go over to the uh to recliner and i
just start
murdering waters and i just drink as
much water as i can
that's good water from my grill nebraska
awesome yes
i love it in the back i love it
so i just murder water and then go to
bed no
and it doesn't it doesn't hurt it
doesn't it doesn't it helps out that i'm
working out as much as i am so i'm like
i don't want to get [ __ ] up you know
because i gotta i'm
run in the morning i run five miles in
the morning and then i'm working out
with a trainer
in the afternoon no day drinking no
i haven't no no no i take that back i
did it uh saturday
all right no bert one day a week yeah
it's not listen
it's six days that kills you yeah yeah
so
sadly a little day drinking ain't gonna
kill nobody it's saturday saturday we do
this
saturday we do this workout with our
girls and the tr and our trainer
and like some friends will come like the
hay slips sandy will come over
and we'll do this like kind of family
workout and then
and then it ends around four and that's
we opened a bottle of tequila
for the rocks tequila and we did polar
plunges
we were doing three minute polar points
i love it what did you think about ron
white getting
quitting drinking ron white quit
drinking ron white
quit drinking
what the are you serious listen during
this pandemic
people are gonna look within like even
you did you cut you're drinking by 70
percent
it sounds oh i've cut my drinking by so
much but
i cut my weed intake by 70 percent
you know it's crazy that people just
went up that some people just started
drinking more
that's the truth a lot of people gonna
go to rehab a lot of people are [ __ ]
eating pills like that going out of
style listen when this thing started
i had 12 years you know how they send
you
every 90 days you get your prescriptions
from scripts
express scripts when you're sag you get
prescriptions sent to every 90 days
whether you need them or not they just
send them to you
so they were sending me those little
footballs yeah
you know how many times i took those
like in the 12 years they sent them to
me
i would take them on the road in case i
couldn't sleep
[ __ ] like that i never really had that
anxiety that
i started getting i would get anxiety
once in a while you go to the store you
got to follow somebody
you get a little bit of anxiety but no
the day they announced this thing
and what happened i started eating those
[ __ ] pills between the pills the
edibles the reefer
i was going i was just passing on the
living room you know
so when before i moved
i started tapering off the [ __ ] pills
the anxiety medication i got here i went
to a doctor they
gave me a different anxiety medication i
said go [ __ ] yourself
that's the one people are killing
themselves that other [ __ ] i just said
i'm just going to go
raw dog it breathe it out work out
and don't think about it and the more i
talk to people
i would go to lunch with rich foss i
would go to lunch with jimmy florentine
and then i would talk to you guys on the
phone and see how you're doing you
theo joe eddie this one that one
and through time my anxiety started to
lower
you know once i started doing comedy my
anxiety went up because
the guilt kicked in what if i'm here
being stupid
i'm not even writing new material i got
no new material i'm
up here wearing these people out what if
one person comes in here with covet
do i need this in my life and then
somebody came through with covert twice
they closed for a week
and i got you know i got replacement
knee surgery
so it's fine i'm done with the pt i went
through it i'm off the pain pills
but i ripped my it muscle just a little
bit so they had to go in and
just repair it just so it heals right
and [ __ ]
i can't i mean my leg feels like a like
a hard dick you know when your dick is
hard
that's how my knee around it just feels
[ __ ] hard than [ __ ]
so until everything goes down i get
vaccinated then we'll talk about comedy
for right now
i'm going to focus on the podcasting my
daughter's softball she got a green belt
in jiu jitsu
she's a little savage we just joined the
swim club
we're gonna i'm gonna take it to a
different beach every wednesday
you know new jersey's got 18 [ __ ]
beaches oh yeah
so every every [ __ ] wednesday we're
going to a different [ __ ] beach
we're going to eat breakfast here but
eat lunch and dinner down the beach
oh and i'm gonna we did that we took
that's the best that's the best there's
the little trips
one morning you know isla cannot wake up
in the mornings and one morning i love
one night
it's like 10 o'clock at night and aila
says
it just rained really hard she goes hey
can we go up to mount baldy and see snow
tomorrow morning
and i was like yeah but if you if we do
that cause we had stuff going on during
the day i said if we do that we gotta
get up at like
four in the morning get up there at six
a.m so the sun's coming up
we'll go see snow and then we'll just
hang out for like 30 minutes an hour and
then we got to drive home so we had to
do [ __ ] at 10 and she's like i'll be up
joey i had so much fun with the girls
in the car at four in the morning isla
was like a jabber job
she had she had she had a rock star
energy drink
and she had never had one and she's just
next to me like
like she's on coke and we're going to
buy concert tickets she's like this is
going to be the greatest day ever like
just going off
we had so much fun and then the girls
would get rally they'd be like dad
socially distant because i was i was
really strict about it because they're
like
so should have said let's go to the
beach watch sunset and i was like [ __ ]
it let's go
and so we'd all get in the car liam
never went with us leanna was like you
guys go
get in the car go down and see the go
down to the beach have a [ __ ] blast
drive home i dude i i've got to be
honest with you joey i'm
you know how much i've been gone this
my career like i i'm i'm a road guy like
i go on the road and i'm
cool with it i i get that's my job
that's what i do but man being able to
spend time with the girls
at this age when they this was the last
year they were gonna be gone
out the [ __ ] door this is it man just
one extra year just one year
i got one year to spend with them and it
wasn't even the whole year but god it
feels like it
every night at eight o'clock i sit there
we meet upstairs about ten to eight
we watch jesse bunked and big city
greens
and i sit there and i ask myself when do
i put a gun in my [ __ ] mouth
and then i go whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa
this is what normal people do yeah we
haven't been normal
for 29 years i haven't acted normal i
didn't go to a wedding
i didn't do a thousand things i was
supposed to do in the name of [ __ ]
comedy
and now i sit there every night from
eight from 7 45
to 9 30 watching disney channel ready to
blow my [ __ ] brains out but i go you
know what in four years i'm not gonna
have this
she's gonna be one she's not gonna wanna
hang out with me she's gonna wanna watch
tv by herself she's gonna be 12
13. so for me this and for guys like you
this was a blessing in disguise
there was a [ __ ] yes uh silver cloud
to this because we got to spend time
with the people who needed us the most
how many times did we [ __ ] book a
date
and then your wife tells you that on
that date there's something for the kids
and you do it and you feel like a
[ __ ] jerk off that's what people
don't understand
we sacrificed you know you're in your
hotel room on a saturday recovering from
a hangover
and you call home to checking with your
wife and the girls are having a great
time their friends are around
and here you are in some [ __ ] bum
[ __ ] town and some hotel room going
you know what man where i belong is
there this is my job
but this is where i belong you know so
it's kind of like you're a walking
contradiction
and that's what it started to become for
me i was a walking contradiction
i'd actually look at the calendar and go
right that week i can't go out
you know how many times i booked the
[ __ ] week of what's that [ __ ] they do
at colfax
the war of the world fair wrote the
world fair i was gone like two out of
the [ __ ] four yeah
you know it just wasn't fair to them so
for me
[ __ ] it i'm gonna take some time off i'm
gonna hang with the [ __ ] girls i'm
gonna podcast my balls off
and i'm gonna have a good time you know
what the money
who gives a [ __ ] about it yeah who gives
a [ __ ] about it
you can't replace what we're doing right
now you can't put a dollar sign on what
we're doing right now which is spending
time
with our girls in a year maybe in 2022
i'll feel a lot better and i'll start
hitting that road like
i'll i burnt chrysler until they put me
in a [ __ ] casket but for right now
i don't want to go fist fight nobody for
half capacity
and 10 people might have covered look
what happened in boulder last week that
could happen anywhere
that could happen anywhere you know
somebody walks into a comedy
club with a [ __ ] gun and a [ __ ]
anxiety pill in their [ __ ] head
and all of a sudden two people get shot
so you know what
i'm gonna mind my business i'm gonna get
healthy yeah i'm gonna get my family
healthy not that they're
not [ __ ] they're great i mean my wife
has friends that just care about her
you know everybody that we were meeting
always can you run a script by your
husband
ah here we go we don't have that here
nobody talks to you about instagram
nobody talks about a script they want to
do a short film that's
that [ __ ] sailed you know but i do miss
you [ __ ] with all my heart
what are you gonna do while you're in
away how are you gonna do two bears in a
cave
uh so we we backlogged a bunch of them
but
tom's just gonna have guest hosts and
then uh and then you know
i'm gonna guest host some so that we can
just have a bunch in the bank
but uh and then bill burt and i bill and
i just do ours on
on on uh zoom anyway zoom anyways and i
i don't think we'll ever go back to not
doing zoom
because it's so easy for both of us you
know he's got two babies
and i'm on the road and bill's you know
built when bill does the road he kind of
shuts down he's not like a
multi-task kind of guy he's like focused
on the road
and so i'm on the road i can do it i
[ __ ] work up until the show
and then um yeah and then and i
backlogged a bunch of burp casts we
got a new studio and uh and
i i think i'm just gonna i think i'll
probably tell i think this year probably
saved my life i'll probably tap off a
booze
during that time away and then and then
for the other thing too
i think i'll be off a boost for that
although one of the guys that we're
doing it with
uh is a big weed guy so maybe i don't
know but
i don't know but uh but i i don't men
i'm
part of me is like i look you know
i also had that instance where i watched
tommy break his knee and break his arm
and that [ __ ] me up like little things
joey like me and you are sensitive
to little things like little things will
flip us where we're like
god damn it and the thing that [ __ ] me
up joey was that
they walked in you know tommy's in the
most pain i've ever seen him in
his entire life and the nurse comes in
and she goes
uh i'm gonna take your blood pressure do
you drink and he was like no
she's like do you smoke and he's like
nah said do you use drugs and he was
like
edibles to sleep and all i thought joey
is that if this was me
i my blood pressure would be up my i
drink all the time
i don't know what pills you can put me
on i was drinking when we did it
i don't like all that [ __ ] i just was
like [ __ ] man i gotta get i gotta get
like legit healthy like lower my blood
pressure
get in shape i'm we were playing
basketball i was like 257
the fattest i've ever been 257 i look
like i'm pregnant
and it should have been me that got hurt
you know i look at tommy
he's in good shape he's 235 at the time
and then he's the one that got hurt
and i had to take him i had to take him
i had to get him out of his car
into the downstairs i had to get him
comfortable
in a on a sofa we had to set up a sofa
before he got to us i had to show up the
next morning with a wheelchair and
and a walker and get him off that sofa
into a wheelchair into a a medical
transport and then driving them in a
medical transport in a [ __ ] pandemic
go to an orthopedist then go from the
orthopedist
to the doctor at cedar sinai get him
checked into the emergency room i spent
the [ __ ] five hours with him
in the emergency room it was like it was
such an event
that it made me realize how fragile life
is and like
if you're not prepared for the worst to
happen physically
then you're [ __ ] you're [ __ ] and i i
just was like i have no muscle i don't
lift i don't
lift weights um i run but i'm i'm but my
running is like i drink a bottle of wine
on the treadmill you know like i'm not
i'm just making sure i enjoy it and i
just i woke up the next day i called joe
i apologized to joe
i was like joe you always told me to
watch out for my knees
i didn't know what that meant and he
started laughing he goes what do you
mean i go
i just thought you didn't know how knees
worked like i thought you were like
how i go how the [ __ ] was i going to
hurt my knee and then i go tommy blew
out his knee i didn't understand you
knew what you were talking about
joe's told me so much [ __ ] where i just
blew him off or i was like
the [ __ ] you talking about lifting
weights why do i need to lift [ __ ]
weights what a
what's a kettlebell swing gonna do for
me i'm gonna get on the treadmill open a
boxing line
have a good time i'm fine i'm fine and
i i was like i was like i changed
everything i got a trainer immediately
uh got [ __ ] started running
aggressively on the treadmill
and running outdoors and uh and it's
like i mean i'm talking like legit like
work out for 55 minutes lifting weights
i've got today at like uh 2 o'clock my
time
i'm i go i'm with my trainer we'll work
out for an hour
and then i'm going to do recovery ice
bath do a sauna
do a podcast at 4 with chris porter have
a
couple glasses of wine roll home murder
some water
sleep good read a book and [ __ ] and
i'm telling you joey i really think
i think when i look at this year so many
weird things happened
and lined up and i witnessed you know
whether it's
being on the road and seeing the way
people behave during a pandemic or
or going into the small comedy clubs and
getting scared and then and then
adjusting my behavior or whether it's
being home for the first three months
and not touching booze or drugs
and just going like i'm gonna be clean
i'm gonna be healthy and
and or if it's just like hey not every
night has to be me chasing
spots at the club maybe at night when
your girls are home you get a chance to
go hey let's
let's watch let's watch uh like a series
together let's all get
into a series and watch all that series
and we'll watch two episodes a night
like little changes like that joey
that's what i did we all had to do it
yeah we all had to adjust i started
playing the guitar my man mike gave me a
[ __ ] guitar
i've taken five lessons already i find
myself practicing i started with 10
minutes
now i'm up to 45 minutes last night i
turned the tv
off at night once my terry goes to bed i
turn the tv off
that's it there's no i've already seen
everything what a new [ __ ] show i
can't sit there and focus on a new show
i can't even comprehend it so let me
just practice the [ __ ] guitar
i'm up to my second song i'm playing i'm
learning you know
so it's like this was a blessing in
disguise we all needed to get off we
were on a ferris wheel that we couldn't
get off
no there was no there was no hopping off
there was no there was nothing
i set my tour i this is my year went
like this it we we did the cabin
in in whatever january but that or no no
we shot the cabin in november didn't we
i don't know i thought it was no no we
shot it in january we shot it in january
shot it in january and i was like it was
like all right
you shoot your special in november
you're going to work every week in
december to write a new hour because
you're shooting the cabin in january
you start your tour at the end of
january and then you go from january to
june
and then we're going to take a couple
months off to maybe do something and
then you're going back on the road
i mean it was like you're right when
you're talking about a ferris wheel it
was it was going fast as [ __ ]
faster than [ __ ] faster and i didn't
realize it till after i got off it
three months four months five months
now we've been off it for a year and you
go what the [ __ ] was that
what the [ __ ] was i living what the [ __ ]
was i doing
and it was all fine you know we were
great it was a great [ __ ] time
the store was great i mean but dude
like it's almost like it's almost like
we got a little period
you know i'm not saying like look things
change things change
and things changed you know that period
of life i got to live
where it was all of us in la we were all
starting podcasts
we were all loving doing podcasts just
going in
getting high getting drunk talking
reckless just making each other laugh
[ __ ] as hard as we could and getting
those people that found
that because we've started it and people
found it at the same time
and you'd go in and do [ __ ] the ice
house chronicles where it was
all of us just tag teaming doing spots
and getting [ __ ]
wasted having so much fun and then going
to the store
and like the lineups just being like the
most
insane lineups you've ever seen in your
entire life
that's that is that is a slice in comedy
i i hate to say things have changed but
they have you know i think it
changed for change for the better for a
lot of things i think it'll be fun to go
down
like me and you were talking about going
down to austin and getting to experience
that world
that's going to be fun september
i will meet you in austin i'm going to
do uh
jre i think hopefully hopefully with
the creator of the sopranos david chase
to promote the movie that comes out
september 24th so that's what i'm hoping
so i'd love to see you down there i'd
love to see you when you come back from
uh wherever the [ __ ] you're going
and i'm i'm gonna i'm gonna be going i'm
gonna show
once everything opens up i'm going to be
traveling a lot and go and
go out to new york and spend time in new
york you know like
and go all right i want to i want to see
big j i want to i want to spend some
time at the in the city doing spots i
want to go out
and see you and terry and mercy i wanna
come i'm gonna you know go out to where
all you guys are have dinner with
everyone
like voss and florentine and you and
like go do like i really wanna
because i think you know or go to austin
and stay there for like
i was telling joe i was like you know
i'm going to be there for a week
every month to do two bears one cave and
i go i plan on being a regular
hit at in austin and
you know being a regular in la and just
looking at things and the way that
things work now with zoom
you can live wherever the [ __ ] you want
if you want to travel
yeah yeah if you want to travel you can
travel
bird i uh i miss you i miss your family
i miss you so much man
uh i don't know what you're gonna do
once tom leaves that's your other
support half over there
it's just me and whitney you and whitney
we had a and bert and bill
you know going nowhere you know uh
sebastian
sebastian still stayed yeah has anybody
talked to him
yeah i did i did i'm he's doing a
podcast we're doing a podcast in a week
um i just did his i just did one of his
shows with him he's great
he's i mean it's a small group that's
staying out here but i think you got you
know you guys will come out for
you know for at times to shoot stuff and
do stuff and
maybe the store is sort of like this i'm
gonna let this blow over
i'm gonna fall in love with stand up
again yeah
and then uh we'll see each other but if
not
just plan on september in austin for
sure september in austin let's make it a
date
date it's done i love you i love you
joey i'm happy you took the time today
to do this because i was just dying to
see i was telling
people that you know we talk that's
great you talk on the phone you say
hello
but to see somebody and to see him a
year later and to see how we've
progressed and that we're still
here and that our podcast is still good
and we're trying
it it's just [ __ ] great bird i miss
you i'm gonna miss you when you're away
if you could text me from time to time
and just say what's happening
[ __ ]
i don't think i could i don't think my
text will reach half around the world
but
just keep me posted say hello to
everybody and keep loving those girls
because i know
i think that's what happened here also
our house got so much stronger
there were two things that were going to
happen for guys like you and me
either we were going to divorce leanne
or terry
or our love was going to get stronger
either they realized how much of a loser
we were when we were around full-time
because you and i were type of guys that
we're around full-time we're big
you know what i'm saying there's booze
there's reefer there's smoke coming out
of the [ __ ] rooms
and uh what's the story on netflix they
renewing your show
what have you heard i don't know i don't
know we're gonna
i i'm kind of just playing it by ear i
got so much other [ __ ] going on i'm like
i wanna i love working for netflix man
that netflix was the greatest goddamn
partner
that i've ever had during this pandemic
because it's a great [ __ ] show
a special in the cabin both come out
during a pandemic and everyone's got
netflix
i could not thank this group of people
enough
enough for the opportunities they've
given me i will do whatever they want to
do in the future
i will do it for whatever they want to
pay me i don't give a [ __ ]
they [ __ ] i had so many people come
up to me and compliment me on the cabin
oh dude you murdered the cabin because i
forgot all about it that's how i [ __ ]
up
the pandemic took me all away from it
then i saw a trailer for it
and i'm like [ __ ] they cut me from the
[ __ ] kid from the get killed
it did it was like the number one um
unscripted series on netflix for like a
few weeks
like uh it was like not trending now it
was trending
you're like when you if you can get
trending that's [ __ ]
that's big numbers and it it murdered it
was
i got a call from netflix right when it
right when it's dropped and they were
like
they were like enjoy your success enjoy
your smash hit and i went holy [ __ ]
now i know where the emu is i never knew
what an emu was before that
now we did that all before cancelled
culture was big
we did everything and you were telling
us don't do it
don't do it i don't want to be in this
shot
i just uh my daughter you know she's
getting older so
she's thrown away she's getting rid of
some toys and in the garage when i
pulled in today
you know i knew i was going to talk to
you today but for some reason i looked
at
you know she's got her barbie doll
houses downstairs and she goes i'm gonna
get rid of him dad and today i looked at
him and i thought about
the night ralphie fell on your dollhouse
if i don't think about that once a week
i'm lying to you
i think about i wish i had video of that
i wish i had do it was doing video on
the podcast because my favorite was
me and you ralphie's sitting right there
you're sitting right there i'm sitting
right there
and you're telling me a story and
ralphie falls asleep oh my god and you
don't stop telling the story
you just look at me raise your eyes
point to him and go
and you just keep telling your story and
we can hear him going
i think i'm saying player this vape is
too strong
he kept hitting the vapor pattern he
kept saying player this vape is too
strong
but when he fell in the dollhouse i
remember you and i wanted to laugh and
we couldn't
and i remember he had me outside and i
could not [ __ ] laugh in this
face like rafi i gotta go when i got in
that car
i just broke down i remember i went
around the corner i passed the starbucks
and i had to pull over off the laurel
canyon and laugh
and call you and you are still laughing
so every week
you're in my thoughts when i think of
ralphie falling into that [ __ ]
dollhouse
i love you [ __ ] thank you very
much for coming on today my best
to your family and uh we'll talk when
you get back but i'll see you in austin
in september
awesome joey send the girls my love i'll
talk to you guys brother love you
brother stay blessed me too
all right i hope you enjoyed it as you
can tell the
love is still there between us nothing
ever ended uh
i wish him all the best i love that you
guys love him
i love that he became bert christian i
love that he's the [ __ ] party animal
that he is
and uh you guys saw what i saw when i
looked at that
thank you very much for watching thank
you very much for your support thank you
for your support on patreon
and all across the board listen when it
comes to this podcast
it's all i'm doing right now so i'm
going to give you 100 of my heart into
it all right
thank you very much for watching and now
for a word from my [ __ ]
sponsors
all right i want to thank you guys for
listening on a wednesday morning burt
was great
uh you could tell by a conversation that
we really dig each other i still miss
him i miss him as [ __ ]
i'm gonna miss him when he leaves for
[ __ ] three months who am i gonna call
who am i gonna bother ghostbusters
but i'm happy you guys got to see him
and i'm happy we got to do the podcast
but before we go
real quick i got to mention a few things
to you
from the heart of jersey to join us is
brought to you by draftkings listen
i love draftkings why because they're
fun i'm not a [ __ ]
gambling [ __ ] fanatic i don't know
much about it
i know exactly what you know but listen
i like to have fun
and during this pandemic it's been
boring and draftkings
has really been a pleasure just small
little bets
boost little you know little teasers you
have some fun the other night to ucla
and they covered against michigan you
know he's just having fun
i put a little better on saturday i lost
no big deal but let me tell you
something
tomorrow is the biggest golf tournament
of the year the masters all right
the boys are getting ready to hit the
[ __ ] links and you better be ready
for the [ __ ] action draftkings is
america's top rated sports book act
why because they're the [ __ ] best and
they give you a shot
a shot to land in the [ __ ] green all
right
you get 100 to one odds if a golfer of
your choosing
finishes in the top 10 joy what are you
talking about what i'm telling you is if
you pick a golf and they finish in the
top ten
if you put one dollar down you're going
to win 100 it's that simple
pick any golfer from this week's
tournament if they finish in the top 10
you get a yard stick
don't all you got to do is sign up at
draftkingsportsbook app now
choose your golfer before the tournament
tees off tomorrow morning well you don't
have a dollar
go [ __ ] yourself you're lying to me
draftkings are safe
secure and reliable so you can deposit
and withdraw your funds and your
convenience
it's a hole in one golf ain't your
[ __ ] thing i don't blame
you whatever to each his own i like
vanilla you like chocolate
you got nba basketball and you got
baseball where the lines are softer than
[ __ ] hell
so if you should be looking at anything
you should be looking at baseball right
now because nobody
really knows what the [ __ ] is going on
for the next two weeks
this is your chance to make a [ __ ]
killing but i'm not promising you
anything
we know what i'm promising you fun
genuine old-school fun
so download the top-rated draftking
sportsbook app right now today
it's [ __ ] wednesday what the [ __ ] are
you waiting for use promo code joey
when you sign up to turn one dollar into
100
if the golfer you're choosing finishes
in the top 10 of this weekend's
tournament
that's coach joey to turn a dollar into
a hundred for a limited time only and
draftking sportsbook and again
i got nba we got cards we got blackjack
we got casinos we got
poker what what what are you waiting for
you're sitting there [ __ ] watching
law and order for the 80th [ __ ] time
take [ __ ] twenty dollars
download the draftking sportsbook app
right now
and just put a dollar on a golf for the
star and then if you see something
there should be some mba maybe you want
to play blackjack there you go
but you got to be 21 older new jersey
indiana pennsylvania only
new customers only restrictions apply
see draftkings.com
sportsbook for details now if you got a
gambling problem we all got problems i'm
not putting you down
but call one eight hundred gambler or in
indiana call one eight hundred nine
one eight hundred nine with it but if
you're [ __ ] straight and you can
handle it you just want to have some fun
and make a little money on the side
draftkings is the way to go download the
draftking sportsbook app today
use promo code joey and turn a dollar
into a hundred dollars the joint is also
brought to you by
cbd lion listen to me
when it comes to cbd everybody's got
something
[ __ ] to tell you what i do know is
cbd lion told me the truth
from the [ __ ] start how with that
third
party lab results but you got to go to
cbdlion.com right now to start
read read the third party lab results
read about how cbd
cbn cby could help you
in your daily [ __ ] life right now but
it starts with you by going a cbd
lion whether it's a chocolate whether
it's the kinesiology tape you can use
for your shoulder and your knees
whether it's the cream you could use or
the tincture under your tongue at night
to help you fall asleep a little
easier the gummy bears the raspberry the
tropical
cbd lion has you covered go to
cbdline.com right now
pressing code joey your church and get
20 percent off delivered right to your
[ __ ] house
it doesn't get any better than that and
you don't got to take advice from some
[ __ ] guy that got a ged
at a [ __ ] liquor store get your light
together [ __ ]
so go to cbdline.com right now
and downloading the download just
pressing joey
or church it's over the week is over
i'll be around on patreon if you need me
i'll be around on twitter i'll be around
on [ __ ] instagram
but besides that it's great i want to
thank burke christ again but most
importantly
i want to thank you [ __ ] for
always
having my back thank you and have a
great week
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
so
you